I guarantee that if when we have a break
yeah and I make a grinder profile for
you by the next time we film you're
going to have so many matches not even
joking you think so the last time I did
that as a joke to somebody the last time
I did as a joke everything matched the
joke was on you yeah then the joke was
on me because I dated all those guys
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of careful boys today we have all of
your favorite careful boys in the
episode except for Anthony
no one likes him anyways I kind of miss
him dude I'm not clapping that he's
missing I'm just pointing that out is he
missing though because that would be
kind of a different episode we don't
know where he is he's missing he hasn't
texted back in the group chat in like
weeks is he in Vietnam or something or
where is he he's always in different
countries isn't he yeah he's on he's on
a tour right so it's kind of going in is
it Mel Gibson doing a documentary about
him
what that's what I heard the passion of
the Vietnamese Christ now something
about something about kids I don't know
child labor like like Hollywood kid
aficionados
operation uh Anthony Lee child abductor
you wanna you wanna do it in Lee episode
yeah I do I do how do I do that how do I
do that how do we make that happen I
thought you had footage for us or
something no I don't have footage but
what was it I posted that recent video
of everyone roasting on him when he
wasn't here oh man and then he did say
in the comments that he was gonna turn
in his resignation
do you think he misses us yeah yeah
because he texted us about that video oh
yeah he misses it he's like no one's
making fun of me like this is just not
cool out here everyone's praising me and
throwing me flowers do you think when
he's dancing on stage he's thinking
about us while he's up there going [__]
if they could only see me now my glory
my glory
could be I mean yeah that's you think
they will [__] make fun of me he's
like I'll show them dude he's pretty
glorious when he moves yeah but look I
bought this little golf thing for us to
have in the office that where we could
play with Anthony Kinda Yeah I bought it
but yeah but he hasn't been here that's
true oh he hasn't been here since you
got it I got this [__] alcohol
because I don't even drink but Steven
Anthony dude and Anthony's never been
here to taste the wines he's been gone
for like two months huh or about to be
rolling I don't remember the last time
we shot with him because the one time he
was supposed to be here he was like I'm
sick I'm not feeling well
that's a really good Anthony yeah but he
was yeah he was he was like deathly ill
actually
just him talking like this and he's like
moving his head like this because you
know he's all about movements and stuff
like that right he did text me he was
like Hey like yesterday like it didn't
feel good he goes I'm not feeling good
this morning what should I do do you
like this he's like and then he was like
he was like I don't wanna but I don't
want to like let you guys down and all
that you already did but with this text
so I'll just stay home
then knock the boys down you're like oh
well it's okay and he's like okay cool
I'll see you guys next time see you in
four weeks
immediately takes me out I'm like when
it comes to when it comes to feelings
I'm the worst person to text you like go
text someone else there's the feelings
you get that thing where it says Anthony
has his notifications off when you text
him back oh you texting me the screen
goes I'm like bro my [__] dad died
and I still came um I don't give a [__]
what's going on in your life if you want
someone to sympathize go text someone
else obviously that's like that's like
an unbeatable thing you have yeah
can be like man my dad didn't just die
either I'll tell you that
he's always bringing that up every
single time he bails yeah he did it just
died
didn't like go away and sleep I'll tell
you that much
how would we be how do we top that so
then if my dad dies I'll show up even if
we're not filming yeah you have to show
you
we know what the standard is I'm like
this with my mom too what what are you
like like wait sometimes my mama like
like well we're trying to grab like
dinner or lunch or whatever like every
two weeks and then she'll be like
man
we're at IHOP enjoying the strawberry
pancakes just [__] enjoy the goddamn
[__] fruity Tootie there he's like
this is living baby this is living this
is why can't you focus on your
strawberry [__] pancakes look at all
the different kind of syrups we have
here we have butter pecan I'm like where
we're on Atlantic and you're thinking
about Cerritos let's just be on Atlantic
please
[Laughter]
man up mom is the funniest
you get embarrassed when she starts
crying you're just like hey stop crying
stop crying you do that no and then I go
home I tell Gio what happened she
[__] yells at me
the best thing about that is Bart going
to go being like can you believe this
[__]
strawberry pancakes
and then he has to learn that that was
that was [__] up actually she has to
turn him around and go no no that was
funny oh like an hour conversation and
he's like I don't know I don't get your
point
and bar has a oh moment and he goes [__]
I don't get it but I guess I have to do
it now and he's venting to us I'm like
yeah Geo's like getting mad at me it's
like I don't understand is your wife on
your back your back like this
he's like we're on Cerritos we're not in
Atlanta
she doesn't understand that why do you
want to destroy your pancake strawberry
Cafe Moment by [__] seeing his
hanging ass
you're bumming me out
what does Geo say to you like what did
she tell you
just yells at me like oh like you know
it's pretty traumatic and all that and
she's like You Gotta Be You Gotta Be uh
you gotta empathize you gotta see where
she's coming from and try to like
like don't use the triggers that's when
I was like a kid you know like when she
used to come at me like I think probably
because she shut off my feelings when I
was a kid so now it's like a really
natural Niche reaction no no
no I do actually yeah
that makes sense yeah I can't wait to
like take all her [__] stupid ass
Buddhist philosophies and then like
and then [__] counter on her ass you
know feels good dude my parents were
still sheltered about sex stuff that I
love rubbing in that I'm [__] they're
my parents
any chance I get yeah just rub it in
they know everything about your foot on
Nikki's face put on Nikki's back of her
head oh backwards that's barbaric
sometimes yeah
[Laughter]
in front of her face that's just
disrespectful all right
I'm always wondered what the appropriate
response is to when a mom says I can't
get the image out of my head draw a
picture
tell her to draw it draw it in your
pancakes
well if you think about it maybe that is
a cathartic way of getting it out she
[__]
probably but probably not
because then you're gonna eat the
pancakes it's gonna go back into you
that like
uh she was like um I think I tried I
think maybe I have like a um like a
two-week grace period you know oh so
when the incident happened when the
incident happened she's like oh like
this is really traumatic oh yeah for
sure I get it so I went straight to her
I stayed with her in her room I slept in
the same room as her for the whole week
to be support and I'm like okay cool
like the time's running out of this
[__] grace period and then she was
like still feeling traumatic she's like
you know what I'm just gonna sell the
house I just gotta lose this energy I
don't want to think about anymore every
time I pull up into the garage I get
that image I'm like dude I totally get
it so let's help you sell the house we
sell the house now it's been
six months after the house is sold I'm
like [__] the [__] house is sold I
don't know what the hell you're still
thinking about we don't got any of these
[__] things like like lingering
triggers anymore and then so now the
grace period is over you know yeah it's
over yeah
take it too long to cope remember when
but when uh this happened Bart texts the
boys and he's like hey
you guys are my friends and if any of
you ever needs anything let me know and
now we know the clock starts then
there's a shot clock yeah yep look at
the calendar okay Market two weeks when
did I say that
I was like hey Bart can I can can I get
some help but he's like
hey dude what happened oh you know what
we never asked you uh remember how like
so when you brought your realtor friend
here we asked him some questions about
like how to sell a house if someone had
like passed away and he said that you
have to like disclose the info if they
ask you have to disclose but you don't
have to you don't have to be proactive
and then like oh so did you run into
anything like that when you were trying
to sell no one ever no so what my mom
what my mom ended up doing is uh she
sold the house to one of her time
traveler friends no right
[Laughter]
because I think my mom was so like
traumatized with the event that she was
like [__] but what if like we go through
an actual escrow process and then people
ask they have to reveal it and then it's
gonna be re-triggering whatever and I
was like I was like just let sign me
over to be your power of attorney and
I'll sell the house and try to maximize
profits for you
but then I just think like [__] when
a [__] is frazzle dazzled then she
can't think straight [__]
I mean sometimes I feel that way yeah
yeah so she was just like I'm just gonna
sell it to my [__] because that time
childhood friend came over and kind of
like did like a a week-long exorcism you
know if she got a good deal yeah she
sold it like it was like 100 G's under
like marketing those Time Travelers are
con artists dude I don't think they're
from the future I really don't you're
not buying it starting to not think so
I'll Farm but I was like fine if this is
what's gonna make you feel good [__]
go ahead yeah maybe because a time
traveler was like oh my God inflation's
that much more right now they're like oh
I kick just came from the 90s houses
weren't this expensive and your mom felt
bad yeah 100 G's under and I was like
dude that's a good deal and they didn't
know they didn't know about anything
like the buyer no because that that lady
was the person that came over and helped
my mom like conduct exorcisms like the
whole week yeah yeah because I
apparently there's like demons and [__]
in there now there's just Dad right and
then so it's I don't know so like it's
just Dad I see him
and I'm like Hey Dad see you later you
know
she's saying [__] like that yeah oh
assistant did you have a dream last
night because I had a dream and I felt
like the presents come over my mom's
like she eats it up she was like oh your
dream what's your dream she's like oh he
came to just say like goodbye one more
time or whatever you know my mom like
just eats all that [__] up those guys
probably love her that's just her
[__] REM sleep speaking to her like
I'm like I don't know dude
you know
mine's going crazy
she got such a good deal out of that man
yeah I feel like all those people are
con artists and they try to [__] wrap
around your life and then try to extract
everything out of you
and taking advantage of a frazzle
dazzled [__]
and all you gotta do right listen
sometimes you feel that way sometimes
you feel frazzle Dazzle it's a real term
yeah I could have gone over with some
incense and [__]
that's what the lady did see that's all
and then I got a 100K discount on the
house damn okay dude they're really good
because they come over like during like
a time of Crisis yeah and they really
help during that time and then so they
don't really like
charge anything they just have like like
front load a ton of Goodwill and then
later on it's like yeah that Bart's
[__] shaking his watch like all right
isn't that also like the Scientology
business model is it they come to you at
a time of like distress to like kind of
pressure you to is that what Colts do in
general yeah that's why like that's why
they build Scientology places so close
to Kaisers and other hospitals you know
no way like look at the Hollywood
um the the Scientology centers always
have like a hospital really close by why
because they like to go to the emergency
room and get some followers I mean it's
just like an easy way to like prey on
people that are at their lowest is there
a hospital off the 101 off the the
Scientology building was it Franklin or
something yeah yeah it's that's this
that's the big one it's like right next
to the hospital yeah literally shares
the same parking lot the cell of the
cult leader like who sits the husband
and wife down and explains to them that
he's gotta [__] his wife too it's so
good oh my gosh like imagine picture
that dude every documentary I watch on
Cults they end up [__] the wife and
somehow the husband sucks the guy's dick
too yeah
how do you do that it's like I don't got
ten percent but I can suck your dick
this is why it's not working so far in
this cold we're not [__] yeah and
then they're like oh I can feel it nice
man yeah my life is in pieces of [__]
right yeah so all I gotta do is suck on
your dick and you gotta [__] my wife
okay
all right let's do it does that mean the
term sex cult is redundant title it
seems like because all cults have sex in
it yeah what cult doesn't exactly yeah
suicide call what called wooden
if it's on the table it wasn't Heaven's
Gate
really no I thought they were all just
drinking the Kool-Aid no but the guy the
leader was like [__] all the other
dudes in there oh really yeah he was a
gay man
if it's all dudes [__] each other is
that so bad for society but if it's as
long as the ages are all lined up yeah
otherwise because they got to be lined
up yeah yeah
it's gonna be a straight line you don't
want one of these where it's like 13 to
70. you want like you know everyone's
like kind of like 35 or something yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh it gets
weird have you seen that documentary
about that Japanese sex cult no it's
pretty that just sounds like Japan but
it's very low it's like I don't know I
think there's only like a handful maybe
like a dozen members or something oh
really what did they do but then like I
think half of them are like disabled oh
wow wait dude what documentary is this
it's just just type Japanese sex cool it
didn't they're all just like like in
wheelchairs and stuff and like yeah what
kind of disabled right yeah that was my
question yeah there's there's like a
couple of them that are things about
like blind man that just sounds like a
handicapped orgy in a way yeah half
halfway it is yeah how many people do
you need to have in your cult to like be
considered a cult I don't know maybe
there's like a six person minimum or
something that sounds about right you
need a leader need followers I think as
long as you have a leader but what if
it's just like a duel like one leader
one like I think you need enough to fill
a standard Din Tai Fung tape
this what we have here
well we're not [__] so what's our
belief system each other's dicks yeah
maybe we get close but we never do it we
always bail out we get so close and one
of us [__] out that's what makes it
tantalize it yeah yeah that's how you
keep things spicy you don't actually eat
you don't eat the sub
or more religion yeah okay yeah more of
a religion yeah because we hold back
okay yeah like yeah yeah we have values
huh what's up like a club in a tree
house dude if anything yeah I like that
I like it just just kicking girls I try
to come up yeah get out of here
what about our Discord our Discord can
be kind of culty sometimes yeah
we've got some interesting characters in
there man there's definitely quite a few
characters in there sometimes I need to
look more on the Discord if I'm being
honest that's you saying here I haven't
checked the Discord you don't know the
characters do you know who Melanie is I
know Melanie oh yeah I know Melody
she's great we have some regulars in
there but we have a lot of lurkers I
feel like lurkers just read yeah
everybody needs to come in and chat more
yeah I need a chat more too I just don't
know what to say sometimes why don't you
just say that [__] that's what you say
here anyway yeah is this good content
just go in there and just type that out
just go in there and just say yeah all
right he's the same way on JK news the
way he is on Discord same guy he's
probably reading any goals I should
I should not gonna say nothing yeah just
go on there and say that [__] yeah okay
I'll I'm gonna do that today at lunch I
think if they just know you're in there
that's pretty funny it is a cool
Community though I'm gonna send pictures
of me in selfies with everybody in in
the room and just send it randomly
throughout the week just randomly hey
did you like that uh how I respond to
scam callers with your photo now bro
that was [__] hilarious I do that
more than I post my hands are tired from
grappling dude
what did they respond to that like that
sorry my hands are tired
of them took a blurry ass photo that
made it look like he took it because
he's looking at it like this
I'm like sweating I'm like sorry it's
blowing hands tired from grappling
do you use my picture a lot for that
yeah I do yeah because it's just always
there yeah yeah it's a good picture
because I keep re-saving it so it's
always at the front of my camera roll
especially when they're asking for me to
send a picture or the caller like it's
just the perfect it's the perfect setup
I do can we start setting up grinder
profiles with Dick's pictures yeah look
at the grapple
is that illegal to do is it well not if
I give you my consent no I mean but is
that faking an identity I mean is it
illegal again I mean to the dude that's
hoping that he's gonna hook up with you
nobody gets arrested for catfishing
that's not a crime only people in
California would say is that illegal
yeah right like there's [__] catfish
is all over the [__] place
but this is like six degree premeditated
but the funny thing is this guy's gonna
be horny as [__] after all that he's
gonna see him one day and then just grab
Nick and make out whatever it's dirty I
guarantee because I've done this before
I guarantee that if when we have a break
yeah and I make a grinder profile for
you by the next time we film you're
gonna have so many matches not even
joking you think so the last time I did
that as a joke somebody the last time I
did as a joke everything matched then
the joke was on you yeah then the joke
was on me because I dated all those guys
the dentist knows yeah
no my dentist quit
but yeah the um if you really want to do
it that would be a funny what if I got
zero matches and I'd be like wait wait
what hey good because I'm not gay I'll
be like Ryan let me see your profile but
then he goes up to tip and goes do I
still got it
big zero matches like are you kidding me
there's no there's no way there's no
personality about me just let me
flourish it and the whole time I'm
venting her like it's Ryan it's the way
Ryan set up the profile I think that's I
think that's a great episode we just do
an episode where we're actually setting
it up and then we each contribute
personality traits and things like that
what if you did Barts dude no yours dude
yeah Bart's like throwing a [__] net
into goldfish pulled in
yeah what are you talking about dude you
look like a tougher nut to crack and I
think you know that'll be more fun hey
we found out that we found out hey guys
we found out that people want to [__]
Bart is that crazy
that'd be a great episode
what a great episode
thank you
foreign